congratulations for a swot thought the
movie was great thank you thank you
congratulations on having an awesome
prime minister he is pretty good he's
very attractive as well
I feel like this movie I don't know if
this movies made five years ago with for
leading females going into the jungle
and doing the action and the kind of I
guess framework that's laid out for them
I don't know you guys think this movie
is made the way it is five years ago you
know I think we didn't have an idea of
the sort of cultural shift that would be
happening when it came out of course but
I think it's very unusual what Alex did
in general in terms of writing five
great female roles at the center of the
movie and casting it so incredibly with
these women who are just you know you
could watch an entire movie about each
one of these characters and each one of
these actresses and to have everyone's
story in one film I think is strangely
radical because we'd never see it even
though we're very used to seeing like an
all-male cast and it's wild to have that
be like a radical kind of choice in the
film Natalie plays a biologist who
volunteers for a mission alongside an
all-female team to investigate an
environmental disaster zone where
nothing is as it seems
sharks have taste like that it's not
possible you can't cross great
difference babies it's interesting to
hear I mean I think women have always
looked up to your strengths and
obviously what you do on screen but it's
interesting to talk to your cast mates
in here the way they talk about you and
I'm wondering at what point did you say
you mean you mean in a good it's about
you you know um I know you just spoke at
the makers conference and then you know
when did you first decide you know
obviously the woman's March
which was incredible okay at what point
did you say okay I'm ready to take be on
the front lines of this and in addition
to have your peers kind of responded to
that well I've been working with
hundreds of women and many of us have
been working together and it isn't like
you know we like to say we're linked
we're not ranked and we really it really
does feel like hundreds of us speaking
together and I think that gives so much
courage and to feel this solidarity
among so many not just women also men
also all genders those you know who are
non-binary identifying like everyone is
really joining together at this moment
because we've been so lucky to have
these whistleblowers make us aware you
know it was very difficult for all of
these people to come forward of course
and they've opened our eyes to a system
of and culture of harassment abuse that
comes from under representation and in
imbalance of power and it's been a real
privilege to just be in this group of
people who are saying together and
having the power of that solidary
we want things and need things to change
and you know we're so excited about this
new day